this that theme that you just talked
about about millennials not having any
money has come up a couple times and it
seems like
that's one of the threads that kind of
ties everything together
politically and socially right now right
where
if you go back to like the late 60s
again people you know middle-aged people
were looking at the colleges looking at
the youth movement they were like oh my
god like when these people take over our
society like actually go out and get
into authority positions like we're just
i guess we're just done this is the end
of america the end of the world and of
course it turned out not to be that way
because those people got out of college
and they got jobs and bought houses and
had kids and then once you get to that
point you kind of care about what your
community is going to be like in 10
years you care about what kind of
schools your kids are going to you be
that's another way of saying you
basically become a conservative in a lot
of important like dispositional ways
you look at the millennial generation
and so what happens right so every every
like 25 years or so is like when that
happens in the past you get to about 25
maybe late 20s by that point your
parents are starting to be like are you
not going to get married yet like what's
going on there was that that was the
timing of it
the millennials has had like that that
period that young person period has had
so much more room to run because they're
in their mid to late 30s and they're not
able to get married and have kids and
buy houses or create a stable career i
don't think that's it
i don't you know i've heard a lot from
millennials where they're like we'd be
getting married and having kids if it
wasn't for this economy and i'm like i
don't believe it i just i just think
that's an excuse i think
people are just permanent children well
the the economy is in a horrific state
when obama bailed out freddie mae and
fanny
and freddie mac and when we all found
out we were on fiat currency and not the
gold standard in 2007 everybody got the
red pill uh that was like oh and now
we're what are we just are we in
hyperinflation right now i don't know if
you'd call it hyperinflation but we've
just almost doubled our money supply it
is it's i'll call myself out outright
i'm 36 i am not married i'm in a
relationship but we have no kids
that there is something about
millennials where it just it didn't
happen well but values change to
accommodate reality right i mean
like you know i just think about
i was just ahead of this curve i guess i
got lucky for that but you if you're
about 35 about your age
you basically um got out of high school
9 11 happens we've been at war ever
since you've been anything like an adult
right and
all the only politics that you've known
is people screaming at each other
calling each other nazis and so forth
and that's it that's that's our politics
as far as since you've ever been paying
attention to politics that's what it's
been
you just get out of college and like the
year or two after you get out of college
the financial crisis hits and things are
just a waste for several years you
finally start to maybe get back on your
feet in your mid-30s and you're starting
to put something together covid hits
like this is just an incredible amount
of instability for any generation to
handle and you know the millennials are
going to be the first generation in
american history that has a lower
standard of living than their parents do
and you cannot overstate i think
how significant that is right because
it's not just that like oh my parents
had a house that was this big and i only
get a house it's this big what people
related to like what their basic
standard of what a life should look like
is how things were when they were
growing up and so you have an entire
generation of people who in the
aggregate
grew up a certain way and are starting
to realize and understand that they are
going to take a step back from where
that was and that's
you know it is it's not a it's not some
like huge mystery why we get bernie
sanders at a time like this there's a uh
this viral video about pod housing
where people these these companies will
buy like a decently large loft and then
stack up like
like five little cup cubes and then five
on top and you crawl into this little
it's probably
five feet wide no four feet wide
four feet high
and you crawl into your little mat on
the floor with your tv and your art and
that's your pod everyone shares the
kitchen and bathrooms and there's videos
of these millennials being like it's
just so awesome it's only eight hundred
dollars per month and it's just like
oh no for real so much you want to live
you want to live in some of these cities
man
you've look it's only four a month with
a roommate
this is what you're gonna get communism
you're gonna get little hippie houses
buildings where there's gonna be like 50
millennials all living in it and they're
sharing their kids like like their kids
are going to be just communal kids i
mean i saw a tweet and i need to verify
this one but i believe it was from the
world economic forum and it showed young
people about our age living in a tiny
house and it said if you own a big house
you're racist you need to own a small
house you need to own nothing and be
happy about it and i was telling my dad
about this when he came out a little
while ago i said dad i feel a great
sense of
almost resentment but very much a sense
of missing something that we never had
because i know now that the american
dream that i grew up with is not
something that i will ever see i will
never see my white picket fence that's
not something that i'm never gonna have
yeah the american dream that's true the
american dream was based on imperialism
and war yeah it wasn't a real thing i
think one of the issues is
i also think millennials are the first
generation of mass debt
college students i don't think gen x for
the most part was inundated at the same
way the millennials were the boomers
certainly
weren't so one of the issues is i
believe
when i grew up every single adult was
like you have to go to college and i
would just be like why and they would be
alike because otherwise you won't get a
good job and then i'm just like i don't
understand well i've told this story
before i read an op-ed from an economist
i think he worked under clinton where he
said that if you went to any investor
and said you give me forty thousand
dollars in an investment and in four
years you will owe me forty thousand
dollars plus interest and that's it they
would laugh in your face that's the
stupidest investment i've ever heard of
but this is what we're telling every 18
year old to do to take out a loan with
interest that gets them no guarantees
they don't know why they're going to
college they don't know where they're
going to work when they get out and a
bunch of the a bunch of these
millennials went in for liberal arts and
now they're slammed with debt confused
but we had the boomer generation i tell
you man they were screaming in my ears
they would shut up about it so now you
have an entire generation settled with
impossible debt just hating the system
all the problems you mentioned with war
with the financial collapse the security
state and they've just i think they've
just lost the ability to to to function
in any meaningful way relative to the
past generation i think he hit on a good
point it it's something i really worry
about right which is
maybe there are no economic policies
that we're going to have or anything
that are actually going to get things
back to where they were in the 50s and
60s you know maybe all of that was a
just it was a relic of the fact that the
entire world got destroyed and
de-industrialized in world war ii except
for us and they all needed american
labor and american capital and
you know we're five percent of the
world's population we got 30 percent of
the world's resources flowing into the
imperial center and maybe that was just
never sustainable and you just wonder
like even if you know we're five percent
of the world's population if we only got
15 percent instead of 30 percent of the
world's resources we're still
like probably at the top of the heap i
don't think we could handle i i think
there would be a violent revolution if
we had to take a half a 50 cut in our
standard of living in this country you
know and so maybe it was never it was
never something sustainable i think
people just got to learn to go live in
the middle of nowhere and a lot of
people live in the middle of nowhere are
like no you're going to ruin the middle
of nowhere don't tell them to come here
well but that's the difficulty right
like i remember when the yellow vest
protests were going on in france and i
read an article by one of the leaders of
it and the thing he said was
this is true in france it's true in the
united states to a large degree is that
the places that you actually have to go
to work
are becoming increasingly concentrated
in like few urban centers those places
are becoming impossible to actually live
because they're so expensive because
everybody has to go there
it's like you can i mean
there's probably more you know jobs out
in the middle of nowhere if you're
willing to be an electrician or a
plumber or something like that instead
of you know uh but you know we've spent
just
god knows how many hours and and how
many dollars of propaganda to convince
people that that makes them a failure in
their life if they end up doing that so
you know one of the one of the biggest
challenges as we're trying to build this
new studio is
you know we're trying to find a local
expert in folklore mythology but we just
can't find any you know if only there
was someone who can come and read us the
the ancient words that could help us
i how i i have no idea how to help build
a facility only they can do like a
feminist analysis of the epic of
gilgamesh
that would actually be a good bit we
should do where it's like you know in
order to get the uh the new studio built
way to bring in a feminist interpretive
dancer
like you see that parliament thing like
european parliament where they're just
dancing and it's like
oh i think regarding what you said about
standard of living that was interesting
that this would be the first generation
to have a standard of living less than
the generation before and i wonder maybe
financially i agree with you financially
for sure that's what it looks like but
my parents generation got drafted into
vietnam destroyed their standard of
living i mean annihilated the entire
generation he it ruined their lives and
world war one annihilated the entire
generation
give them a little more time with russia
we'll see what happens yeah so that's
why i'm so anti-war if you think that
even even considering a war right now is
any benefit you got to understand what
countries do with large un
uh
uneducated and on uh what do you call it
they don't have a job on unemployment
unemployed masses that what the
countries do with those people they send
them to war to die so they don't have to
feed them and take care of them so you
do not want to push for a war
yes
yeah yeah but again i think i think you
made a very interesting point about
america sort of
stepping in after the second world war
and becoming this economic powerhouse
and i hadn't considered that before
and i want to give it some thought but
another point i like to make when it
comes to the change in the standard of
living is the fact that
the workforce really became
oversaturated because we doubled the
labor supply once we decided that rather
than a sole breadwinner rather than the
father representing the family unit
economically and in working we were
going to have both parents work because
that was somehow you know woman's
liberation we ended up in a position
where your average worker now had half
the negotiating power and so i think
that's been seriously detrimental to
this country but ultimately whether
you're talking about you know a crony
capitalist system or a capitalist system
which is
not managed virtuously or a communist
system
in the end you have a really horrific
situation where your average person does
not have property and therefore no
investment in the system yeah this whole
blackrock owning property thing's got to
go let's just uh
let's just uh start from step one and
this isn't a value statement or a moral
statement
women largely entered the workforce
around starting in the 70s and late 70s
right that's when we you know so so i
mean for our parents generation it was
like they were young adults like all of
a sudden women were getting jobs you
know for me i grew up it was always the
case
but once women are in the workforce
you now have
both men and women focused on the
breadwinning aspect of life and no
familial aspect of life so who's gonna
raise the kids well daycare becomes a
question
they now say we need you know businesses
to offer daycare for our kids
or public schooling
the government has to replace the family
yep and that is not going to work out
well for anybody it's this slow creep
where
like uh ted kaczynski the unabomber
right talked about this with technology
how a car is invented and it's like wow
now i can get a car and i can drive
wherever i want like i could only walk
or ride my bike before now i can drive i
have the freedom of the road
let a little bit of time go go by and
now having a car is not an option you
have to have a car to survive in our
society at all and you're commuting 45
minutes to work every day stuck in
traffic and you have no choice it's kind
of similar here like oh wow women can go
out and get a career they can go out and
get jobs now well give it a couple years
and now women have to get jobs both
parents have to work just to survive
because wages have stagnated and costs
have gone up they have a way of working
i never hear the left talk about that
they always show these graphs where it's
like i wonder what happened in 1979 and
then i see this meme where it's like
labor unions started losing power
and i'm like it's true but you double
the workforce and your bargaining power
gets cut in half overnight and not just
that but you've got
you've got somebody who's you know
running a business
and they say to the guy
so tell me about your family it's like
my wife works here and you know we're
planning this and this and i need x
amount of dollars like your wife's got a
job you don't need that much money
mm-hmm
like you're
the collective salary between you and
your wife is going to be 75k you're fine
yeah i think the expectation is that
you're going to be a dual income
household and so you don't need to be
paid a wage that would be sufficient for
supporting a family and just to clarify
something i said earlier
i said that people who don't have
property don't have a stake in the
system
i misspoke they don't have as much of a
stake there's still a stake in the
system but they are much easier to
control
what is the phrase dink is that it is
dual income no kids yeah yeah i think i
think you're right
i mean i think there's some in that like
because i don't want i think property is
very important but i also i don't want
to say like if somebody has no property
then like they're not doing things that
could be selfless or beneficial it's not
just property though it's stability yeah
right like you know i've seen uh every
time i go into an airport i see like a
fast company magazine one of those like
new hip business magazines and it always
have like some kind of cover article
they do it's one of those recurring
articles that they do again and again in
different you know slightly different
ways and it says like how
for this generation you know the young
generation the young people coming up
today are going to change careers six
times throughout their lives and that
the skill of the future isn't going to
be like mastering some skill it's going
to be mastering the art of learning so
that you can go through these changes
like smoothly and it's like well okay
like if you're some super high iq person
with like a good start you know in your
early 20s and you kind of like knew what
you were doing and you got off on a good
start good for you
but what happens when you if you change
change careers six times
throughout your life that's six times
maybe you have to move
six times that your friends get changed
eventually that just becomes i mean i
went to like 35 different schools
between kindergarten and 12th grade and
by third grade i just learned like don't
make friends it's a pointless exercise
right and so people learn uh you know
don't get too attached to the place you
live don't get too sentimental about the
people you meet there
and
so i think there is a loss of investment
you know and then what what they end up
doing as maybe as a replacement a
prosthetic for that is they displace
that sort of
social concern that they have onto some
you know broad social issues on the
federal level or something like that i
think that can absolutely happen i think
that can absolutely happen and you made
a point earlier about how we couldn't
come in and just cut everyone's standard
of living in half and i was i was
mentioning communism and of course i
believe that you know communism is an
unbelievably horrific barbaric system uh
i mean it's not just a matter of people
not having property they i mean they
slaughter people but
at the same time if a communist regime
were to be instilled in the united
states and they were to tell people you
know you have to live in a pod now it
would be much more of a struggle than to
just erode the economic independence of
the american people over time to the
point where they say a pod that's a
really great deal or van life
yeah i remember when uh that there was
this woman on youtube who was po she
posted like two van life videos and
gained like three million subs overnight
because there was apparently some glitch
in the algorithm where she hit all these
key points
and so youtube's algorithm just showed
her videos to literally everyone so she
makes like two videos with three million
subs
but it made me made me think of a
potential conspiracy
that youtube was intentionally promoting
van life as a way of making millennials
happy being happy with owning nothing
for real think about what happened so
when this van life trend was going
around like 2018
all these people are on youtube and
they're like i live in a van i can go
wherever i want i got no rent i got a
computer and my dog and we're going
surfing and then they post these videos
where they're playing that song by i
think it's by avicii he said one day
you'll leave here or whatever the song
it's like on repeat and they're all like
running and like filming themselves life
is so good living in a van down by the
river
and i just i was like i wonder if
youtube's promoting that because they
want people to own nothing and be happy
and then all of a sudden we got that
video from the world economic forum that
said you will own nothing and you'll be
happy i will not live in the pod i will
not eat the bugs it's tough to tell
because it's like calling it you what
does youtube want it's monolithic
corporations don't have wants but
certain people within the corporations
may very well have that in mind i would
think that most people involved hadn't
thought about that or thought that far
ahead it almost seemed like the dream
the american dream is so prevalent that
people had bought it at that point
yeah well no i think regardless even if
it's not the case that there's an
algorithmic push to direct people
towards this kind of content
our generation i would say generations
prior have really been slowly sold this
idea that independence is the most
important thing you can possibly have
right so commitment and productivity are
significantly less important than being
able to do whatever you want whenever
you want and it's true that if you are
just living out of a comfortable van
you're not tied down anywhere you
don't have as high of expenses it's much
easier for you to travel i'm not saying
it's a preferable way to live but it is
the way to live that we have been sold
maintaining over time it's not easy they
can't drive i mean you can but
maintaining a house is really difficult
well yeah i would say maintaining a van
is probably a lot less expensive um
but if you're if you're living in a van
i don't know if you're gonna have the
kind of job that's gonna be you know
yeah unless you're one of those
youtubers well again my whole point is
there's a lifestyle whether it's there's
a lifestyle that's been sold to us
which is that independence is the most
important thing it is far more important
as i said than productivity or
commitment building something in the
long term what matters is you can pick
up and leave and do whatever you want
whenever you want and so it's
unsurprising that it's such a huge trend
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there